las ventas es la plaza de toros más
grande de españa pero hoy en día a causa
de la pandemia solo recibe a los alumnos
de la escuela taurina como el gobierno
mucho mucho porque nosotros nos quedamos
sin poder tórax nada y sin por hacer
nada entonces como que todo lo que
hacemos aquí no tiene
por lo general cada domingo se reúnen
aquí alrededor de 24.000 amantes de la
corrida pero este año no hay un solo
aplauso en las gradas
una razón para poner en duda algunos
empleos que no nos pueden casi pagar
porque no pueden darle espectáculo ni
pueden dar nada pues a ver de qué forma
se arregla no pero pero estamos con poco
muchísima gente que nos iremos al paro o
aguantaremos lo que podamos aguantar
graves sin embargo la comunidad de
madrid dirigida por la derecha
subvencionado el sector con más de un
millón de euros en enero pasado en el
seno de esta escuela municipal el
director es claro el problema es el
gobierno central
somos después del fútbol el sector que
más aporta a las arcas del estado entre
iva y el irpf
solo pedimos que nos traten como
cualquier sector de cultura pero el
gobierno para la desgracia nuestra es
más bien antitaurino
una crítica generalizada en el medio
pues estas plazas vacías son sólo la
punta del iceberg los toros previstos
para los espectáculos quedaron en manos
de sus criadores
este muchos ganaderos se pueden integrar
en el camino ha dejado de ingresar 300 y
pico mil euros por sus toros más lo que
le cuesta el mantenimiento de esas
cabezas en torno al medio millón de
euros fácilmente en el matadero un toro
como éste valdría alrededor de 700 euros
una opción que está lejos de ser
compensatoria isabel considera que criar
un animal le cuesta unos cinco mil euros
aunque por ahora se mantiene con sus
ahorros el futuro le preocupa ya
veníamos con una crisis inicial de que
la gente cada vez tiene otros formas de
ocio y no asiste a la plaza de toros
falta educación falta mostrar a la
sociedad lo bonito que es este animal lo
bonito que es criarlo y la gente
focalizada mucho solo en sus diez
últimos minutos en la plaza
los últimos 10 minutos de vida del toro
han sido estudiados por este veterinario
que denuncia un proceso de tortura
he visto un animal al que se le somete a
un sufrimiento brutal y podéis pensar
que esto cuando se clava pues ahí está
el tope y no va a penetrar más
bueno pues esto traspasa los músculos
del toro y abre un trayecto que se ha
medido de hasta 30 su última el tercero
de banderillas es clavarle esto en los
sitios donde se han clavado las puyas
todo además el sacrificio con la espada
es una operación difícil sólo el 20 por
ciento de las corridas culminan con una
ruptura de la aorta provocando la muerte
inmediata lo que se llama rematar al
toro que esto se utilizaban los
mataderos para matar a los bólidos se
prohibió en la unión europea en el año
jose milita junto con otros 650
veterinarios por la abolición de esta
disciplina quitarle la calificación del
patrimonio cultural y si le quitamos las
subvenciones programa que está muerta
aunque la unesco se niega a reconocer la
tauromaquia esta práctica se ha
convertido en patrimonio cultural de
españa gracias al apoyo de la derecha y
a la abstención de la izquierda unos
socialistas pasivos comparten hoy en día
el poder con podemos la izquierda
radical anti tauromaquia del preocupan
desde luego que a lo que si los puestos
directos e indirectos que se vean
afectados porque esto porque este
negocio desaparezca pero es que creo que
es una es una goma es un hecho natural y
biológico que en estos en el siglo 21 no
tiene sentido no que no premian los
valores éticos de una sociedad
democrática esta diputada considera que
es momento de cortar las subvenciones
regionales unas ayudas que por ejemplo
le permitirían a este pueblo andaluz
organizar su tradicional encierro y la
gente se opone de la talanquera hacia
afuera y lo novillo corren por el centro
de la calle antes del comienzo de la
pandemia
jorge organizaba festivales populares en
todo el país
según el sector taurino la crisis del
coronavirus pone en riesgo 54 mil
empleos
en la puebla del río ni taquillero
portero arenero alguacilillo mulillero
ahora los apasionados temen por su
fiesta popular somos conscientes
realmente del esfuerzo de estos señores
sí que tenemos miedo y muchas veces de
para pensar fríamente y sé tú el día que
noche en esa gente aquí que será de todo
hecho
a la crisis se suma el desamor de una
parte de la población española bajo la
influencia de movimientos animalistas el
público de la tauromaquia no deja de
disminuir